turkey will be on the table as mep  discussed the state of play after a  referendum granted the president's  sweeping new powers too often basic  rider garment workers worldwide are not  respected emmy peas recall for rule that  force actors of the supply chain to be  socially responsible with audio-visual  content so easily accessed Parliament  want to make sure rules on hate speech  ads and protecting minors cover new  media platform any PS will take a  position on controversial Hungarian  legislation targeting foreign-funded  NGOs and universities shopping online  some sellers very prices all block  access to their websites depending on  the country you're in any Peas will  propose ending unjustified geo-blocking  for goods and services such as hotel  booking